T'as changé Squeezie - Shindehai et Sasha
Est-ce qu'à tout hasard
On en aurait pas un peu marre d'être con ?
Il fut une temps il y a 6 ans ou Squeezie naissait sur YouTube
On dirait j'ai 7 ans mon gars
La fleur de l'enfance, c'est quoi ?
Mais désormais, Tout a changé
Un sacré chemin parcouru
On a bien évolué,
On a grandi aussi !
Ça va changer ma vie !
La belle barbe, la belle barbe, la belle barbe !
Ceci est de toute beauté ! :)
T'en rêvais depuis si longtemps de cette pilosité !
Aujourd'hui, aujourd'hui, aujourd'hui
Il est l'heure de se faire tatouer
De faire des voyages et de se cultiver !
Car aujourd'hui c'est différent
Qu'est ce qui s'est passé
Qui s'est passé ?
Squeezie a changé
Beaucoup changé
Le petit est devenu grand
Et surtout aujourd'hui, il est l'heure de il est l'heure de...
La virilité !
~ Hop hop hop ~
C'est quoi cette petite be-bar là ?
(~ Cry me a river ~)
~ Hop hop hop ~
Squeezie viril les gars
Squeezie viril !
~ Hop hop hop ~
C'est quoi cette petite be-bar là ?
~ Cry me a river ~
~ Hop hop hop ~
Squeezie viril les gars
Squeezie viril !
Sur Internet
Sans prise de tête
En à peine quelques jours il perça
Une petite chanson pour vous remercier
De mes 30 z'abonnés
Traçait sa route
Sans aucun doute
En faisant des podcasts sur l'caca
À peine ça commence, c'est surjoué c'est nul
Totalement ridicule !
Ça fait mal, ça fait mal, ça fait mal
Tu veux que je te réponde quoi ?
~ Eh oh eh oh ~
Fallait bien commencer quelque part
Tes origines sont là !
Des années, des années, des années,
Les gens se sont moqués de moi...
~ Eh oh eh oh ~
Mais cette époque là, elle est loin derrière toi !
Car aujourd'hui c'est différent
Qu'est ce qui s'est passé
Qui s'est passé ?
Squeezie a changé
Beaucoup changé
Le petit est devenu grand
J'adore parler anglais
Parler anglais
Y'aura p'têt du progrès
P'têt du progrès
Des causes nobles tu défends
Les temps ont un peu changé
Un peu changé
On peut vraiment y'arriver
Vraiment y'arriver
T'as même ton propre studio maintenant !
Et surtout aujourd'hui, il est l'heure de il est l'heure de...
La virilité !
~ Hop hop hop ~
C'est quoi cette petite be-bar là ?
~ Cry me a river ~
~ Hop hop hop ~
Squeezie viril les gars
Squeezie viril !
~ Hop hop hop ~ (Squeezie)
C'est quoi cette petite be-bar là ? (Oooooh)
~ Cry me a river ~
~ Hop hop hop ~ (Cry me a river)
Squeezie viril les gars
Squeezie viril !
T'as changé, t'as changé
T'as changé Squeezie
T'as changé Squeezie (~ Cry me a river~)
T'as changé, t'as changé
T'as changé Squeezie
Squeezie viril les gars
Squeezie viril !
T'as changé, t'as changé
T'as changé Squeezie
T'as changé Squeezie (~ Cry me a river ~)
T'as changé, t'as changé
T'as changé Squeezie
Squeezie viril les gars
Car lui c'est
Squeezééé
Nan mais attends mec...
Quoi ?
Pourquoi tu dis "Squeezè" ?
C'est "Squeezie" !
...Ah ouais c'est vrai...
T'as changé, t'as changé
T'as changé Squeezie
Squeezie viril les gars
Squeezie viril !
T'as changé, t'as changé
T'as changé Squeezie
T'as changé Squeezie (~ Cry me a river ~)
T'as changé, t'as changé
T'as changé Squeezie
Squeezie viril les gars
Squeezie viril !
Fût un temps j'étais leur troisième chanteur ouais...
Enin vous connaissez, vous avez vu la vidéo N°1
Ah tu l'as pas vue ?
Il a pas vu la première vidéo !
Un grand merci et un grand bravo à Shindehai pour la musique !
N'hésitez pas le soutenir c'est important !
Soit en vous abonnant à sa chaîne YouTube soit en achetant la musique soit en faisant les deux, voilà ! C'est comme vous voulez !
Les liens sont dans la description !
Je vous dis à bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo, au revoir~ !